hey Georgie what's up we're friends
right what do you mean I've asked you
out a bunch
you've made it pretty clear you weren't
interested before I asked out another
girl I just wanted to make sure that is
fine I'll have to think of T cheese as a
more romantic Taco Bell
[Music]
so what do you like to get here what oh
it doesn't matter
multi sign hi welcome to oh hey Georgie
I didn't know you worked here well
haven't seen you in a while
oh you know Jenna from school yeah yeah
of course
hey so can I get you all started with
some drinks I'm good with water water
sounds great refreshing so you're saying
you have no feelings for at all I wasn't
at the restaurant with her I was there
with you
that doesn't answer my question I was
hoping you wouldn't pick up on that did
you take me there on purpose hold on a
second is this one of those spots where
we end up making out of the backseat no
ma'am
hey here you go what's this
it's your tip from the or not I wanted
to give it to you then but I also wanted
to get out of there alive don't worry
about it you sure I'm sure
so how long you been working there a
couple weeks trying to save money for
college well now you have to take this I
insist thank you
how are things Audrina honestly I had no
idea should you even be talking to me
right now probably not I'm glad I am
-
[Music]
I bet the guy who invented this fork is
a millionaire I guess I wonder if his
last name is poor it comes from spoon
and fork a spork
oh my god mine is blown
you know what you should do you cut your
hair what I think it looked better oh
maybe a little beard like George Michael
I wonder how tall he is I bet he's tall